dabei sind wie immer gebe ihnen zunächst
ein paar daten zur lage das heißt die
meldezahlen das sind wie immer die
offiziell gemeldeten zahlen wir wissen
dass es im internet und in bestimmten
portalen auch andere zahlen gibt seien
sie versichert dass das
robert-koch-institut diese zahlen auch
kennt aber wir beschränken uns auf die
offiziell gemeldeten zahlen weil wir die
grenz analysieren und wir sind uns auch
sehr bewusst darüber dass es eine
dunkelziffer gibt das alles sagen wir
immer schon aber es ist nicht immer so
einfach für jeden zu verstehen glauben
sie dass wir dieses business beherrschen
schauen wir uns zunächst einmal die
situation in der welt an
wir haben momentan also stand gestern um
15 uhr waren in china insgesamt 41 81
1000 fälle gemeldet
und wir haben international inzwischen
mehr fälle gemeldet außerhalb chinas als
in china
und zwar waren das gestern um 15 uhr
offiziell gemeldet 86 1661 fälle
das betrifft 146 ländern das zeigt also
das was wir ja wissen es handelt sich um
eine pandemie
es handelt sich um ein virus das sich
weltweit verbreitet und das wird es auch
noch einige wochen und monate tun
das wissen wir seit langem und darauf
bereiten wir uns ja auch entsprechend
vor
in italien gibt es bislang 24 1747
offiziell gemeldete fälle
und von diesen haben wir berichtet von
insgesamt 1809 todesfällen also eine
sehr dynamische situation auf der ganzen
welt zur zeit ist tatsächlich europa im
fokus dieser pandemie
hier haben wir die intensiv zur dynamik
und wie gesagt noch mal hier geht es um
offiziell gemeldete fälle
in südkorea sind mit gestern dem
zeitpunkt 15 uhr 8162 fälle gemeldet
dass eine zunahme von knapp 10%
gegenüber vorgestern
und hier wurden 75 tote gemeldet in
deutschland sind die offiziellen
meldezahlen bei 6.012 gestern
sie finden auf der website der john
hopkins zahlen über 7.000 wie gesagt
diese zahlen kennen wir und die
berechnen wir auch in unsere überlegung
mit ein
aber offiziell gemeldet in deutschland
sind 6000 zwölf fälle das sind 6,9
prozent mehr als vor gäste und in
deutschland wurden bisher offiziell
gemeldet 13 todesfälle
ich möchte ein wenig näher auf
deutschland eingehen und noch mal zuerst
ihnen nochmal vermitteln warum wir
risikogebiete definieren weil das auch
in der öffentlichkeit häufig
missverstanden wird
wir bezeichnen als risikogebiet solche
gebiete in denen bestimmte
voraussetzungen gelten die
erkrankungshäufigkeit ist ein indikator
natürlich und zwar konkurs häufigkeit
eben nicht nur an der reinen zahlen
sondern pro kopf einwohner in der regel
brechen dass auf 100.000 die dynamik der
täglich gemeldeten fallzahlen ist ein
weiterer indikator und natürlich auch
welche maßnahmen durchgeführt werden und
ein wichtiger faktor ist ebenfalls auch
wie viele fälle wurden aus der
jeweiligen region quasi in ein anderes
land verbracht das ist ein wichtiger
aspekt der natürlich auch eine rolle
spielt all diese indikatoren
berücksichtigen wir und ich möchte das
auch gleich sagen das ist auch ein
dynamisches geschehen und es ist kann
auch der zeitpunkt kommen wo wir gar
keine risikogebiete definieren würde es
einfach zu viele werden das ist eben in
einem rahmen einer pandemie so und wir
passen unsere bewertungen kontinuierlich
wie sie wissen jeden tag her an die
situation an
stand heute hat das robert-koch-institut
folgende risikogebiete benannt italien
iran in frankreich die region grau ist
in china die provinz hubei in südkorea
die provinz
düren songbook du in österreich das
bundesland tirol in spanien madrid und
in den usa die bundesstaaten kalifornien
washington und new york
und in deutschland haben wir als
besonders betroffenes gebiet was einem
risikogebiet entspricht den landkreis
heinsberg also die pandemie hat eine
große dynamik das wissen sie und das
können sie auch überall lesen
die zahlen die gemälde nimmt also
wirklich sehr sehr stark zu was heißt
das für deutschland nochmals betonen das
gerne noch mal also wir haben offiziell
gemeldet 6012 fälle in baden württemberg
haben wir bislang 1100 fünf fälle
das ist eine erkrankungsrate von 100 von
9,6 pro 100.000 in hamburg zum beispiel
haben wir 260 fälle stand gestern 15 uhr
jeden tag ändert sich nichts an stand
gestern 15 uhr in hamburg 260 fälle das
sind 13,9 pro 100000 einwohner nur um
ihn ein beispiel zu geben für die
dynamik der situation und um ihn auch
klar zu machen
das ist in verschiedene regionen
deutschlands unterschiedliche fälle
zahlen gibt unterschiedliche regionen
mit unterschiedlichen dynamiken und das
ist auch immer wichtig zu wissen weil
natürlich in den jeweiligen regionen
dann auch unterschiedlich intensiv
reagiert wird und die ärzte auch
unterschiedlich stark involviert werden
das heißt also wenn wir das vergleichen
die zahlen 15 uhr gestern der stand 6200
gegenüber vorgestern haben wir 1000 174
fälle mehr also eine starke den 19 696
einer technisch im ach so na ja ich bin
schlechter rechner bitte ich lese
einfach die zahlen vor
also von diesen 6012 allen die
offizielle bohr bestätigt sind wurden
5433 aus allen 16 bundesländern an das
robert koch institut übermittelt das
heißt zu diesen zahlen haben wir eben
nicht nur die reinen zahlen sondern auch
informationen zu den patienten die sich
hinter diesen zahlen verbergen
die altersspanne der patienten liegt
zwischen 0 und 95 jahre der alters
median bei 46 jahren und 56 prozent sind
männlich und 44 prozent sind weiblich
wir werden ab morgen um eine leichtere
übersicht ihn zu geben ein sogenanntes
dashboard online stellen das heißt mit
diesem dashboard können sie dann die
tägliche anpassung sehen in deutschland
am 18
wird das der sport online gestellt wie
gesagt und dann sehen sie doch die
zahlen aber nochmal das sind wirklich
nur die ausschließlich nach
infektionsschutzgesetz übermittelten
fallzahlen diese dynamik ist für uns die
die entscheidende anhand der wir alles
erfassen aber ich sage noch mal die
zahlen von zb dashboard im
wirtschaftsuniversität werden immer
etwas höher sein
im laufe der nächsten wochen und monate
werden sich diese beiden zahlen aber
immer weiter anpassen
noch ein wort zur lage einschätzung
wir haben heute oder wir werden heute
die risikoeinschätzung für die
gesundheit der bevölkerung in
deutschland ändern
wir werden sie ab heute als hoch
einschätzen
der grund ist ganz einfach sie alle
sehen die dynamik sie werben unter
anderem gestern bereits hat professor
schade ihn auch vermittelt dass es eine
reihe von hinweisen von lokalen
gesundheitsämtern gibt die von einer
sehr dynamischen lage sprechen
das heißt also das ist der grund warum
einfach noch stärkere maßnahmen
notwendig geworden sind um die
verbreitung des virus weiter zu
verlangsamen und die
behandlungskapazitäten nicht zu
überfordern
nochmal ihnen das ins gedächtnis rufen
seit wochen betreiben wir die strategie
der eindämmung und diese strategie der
eindämmung werden wir immer weiter
betreiben jede infektionskette die wir
unterbrechen können verhindert die
weiterverbreitung des virus aber auch
das habe ich schon mehrfach gesagt wir
werden die verbreitung nicht eindämmen
können wir werden sie nicht stoppen
können
aber wir können sie verlangsamen und das
ist der grund für die maßnahmen die
gestern verkündet wurden der hintergrund
für die geänderte risikoeinschätzung
sind die weiter steigenden fallzahlen
insbesondere die in den vergangenen
tagen vermehrt eingegangenen
alarmsignale aus dem öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und von kliniken auch
wir merken das sogar gut aufgestellte
gesundheitsämter und
universitätskliniken inzwischen probleme
haben mit der steigenden zahl von
erkrankungsfällen darunter sind auch
schwere und teilweise sehr schwere fälle
auf den intensivstationen und es gibt
auch immer mehr fälle momentan die nicht
mehr auf bekannte fälle zurückgeführt
werden können
darum haben wir uns entschlossen die
maßnahmen hatten wir ihnen auch letzte
woche schon berichtet dass wir die
gesundheitsämter unterstützen weiterhin
wir werden studierende ausbilden die bei
der kontakt nach verfolgung helfen
dadurch erhöhen wir die kapazität der
gesundheitsämter will nochmal
wir müssen alles tun um jede mögliche
infektionskette zu unterbrechen und wir
werden das in den nächsten wochen und
monaten auch weiterhin tun und wir sind
dabei auch digitale werkzeuge zu
entwickeln um den gesundheitsämtern
ihrer arbeit zu beschleunigen und zu
verbessern
wir müssen aber davon ausgehen dass die
tatsächlichen erkrankungszahlen deutlich
höher sind als die die dem robert koch
institut übermittelt werden
das liegt zum einen an den test
kapazitäten der labore und es liegt
natürlich auch an den übermittlung
kapazitäten durch die gesundheitsämter
denn auch wenn das alles digital erfolgt
muss natürlich irgendwann zu beginn
jemand die daten in die software ein
pflegen das ist ja klar haben wir ein
melder verzug den kennen wir den können
sie auch das sind drei teilweise auch
vier tage
aber die dynamik ist das entscheidende
also dieser melde vorzug ist uns
natürlich auch bekannt und den planen
wir natürlich in unsere überlegungen mit
ein das der grund warum die gestern
verkündeten maßnahmen getroffen wurden
und diese maßnahmen haben den zweck dass
sie die ausbreitung ist virus
verlangsamt ohne diese maßnahmen müssen
wir davon ausgehen dass wir in wenigen
monaten vielleicht mehrere millionen
krankheitsfälle haben und das wollen wir
vermeiden und darum möchte ich alle
bitten dass sie diese maßnahmen ernst
nehmen und nach umsetzen so wie wir das
er seit vielen wochen wirklich fordern
von allen für selber können einiges tun
durch soziale distanzierung also abstand
halten durch dadurch dass wir eben in
die armbeuge niesen dass wir eine
hygiene verhalten an den tag legen und
ein virus nicht weiter tragen
es ist mir auch wichtig zu sagen dass
die gefährdung von region zu region
variiert auch noch mal wichtig zu wissen
das heißt das risiko für die bevölkerung
kann an manchen orten sogar sehr hoch
sein wie das zum beispiel momentan im
land kreis heinsberg der fall ist eine
entscheidende punkt ist der dass die
belastung des gesundheitswesens
maßgeblich davon abhängt und unser
ganzes ziel muss es sein die kapazitäten
des gesundheitswesens so hoch wie
möglich zu fahren uns vorzubereiten
das heißt die kliniken sich vorbereiten
auf eine große zahl von schwer
erkrankten menschen die auch beatmungs
wichtig sind und darum fordern wir seit
wochen die krankenhäusern auf dass sie
ihre kapazitäten hochfahren die intensiv
kapazitäten hochfahren mindestens
verdoppeln und das ist auch machbar das
gelingt auch aber ich möchte noch mal
sagen dass eben wir alle auch durch eine
dadurch dass wir abstand halten dass wir
gegebenenfalls wenn es sinnvoll ist in
quarantäne in die verbreitung des virus
verlangsamt die gesundheitsbehörden vor
ort müssen in den nächsten wochen und
monaten weiterhin alles tun um die
eindämmung fortzusetzen ich hatte ihm
gesagt dass wir sie unterstützen dabei
immer mehr mit allen möglichkeiten ist
sind viele modelle überlegt und wir
werden die gesundheitsämter
heute unterstützen
klar ist folgendes jede person die
isoliert wird und jeder enge kontakt in
quarantäne der familien wird der
verbreitet die verbreiter verlangsamt
die verbreitung des virus wir müssen
dafür sorge tragen dass nicht zu viele
schwerkranke zur selben zeit ins
krankenhaus müssen und dort
intensivmedizinisch untersucht behandelt
werden müssen
darum auch noch mal mein wiederholte
appell an alle landrätinnen landräte
bürgermeisterinnen bürgermeister das
sind ja diejenigen die in deutschland
darüber entscheiden wie vor ort mit
patienten mit den gesundheitsämtern
umgegangen wird
sie müssen frühzeitig erkennen wenn sie
hilfe von außen brauchen es gibt ja
genügend möglichkeiten dass ich von
außen hilfe zu holen sie müssen
frühzeitig den ernst der lage kennen
jede ihnen angeboten unterstützung
wahrnehmen
auch die kliniken die bislang noch nicht
so stark betroffenen müssen jetzt jetzt
in diesem moment so wie es am wochenende
auch gefordert wurde von minister sparen
jetzt sich darauf vorbereiten ihre
elektro portionen runterzufahren und für
die intensivbetten hochzufahren
wir fordern das seit vielen wochen und
nochmal ganz klar halte ich wir erwarten
dass von allen hospitälern dass sie ihre
intensiv kapazitäten mindestens
verdoppeln aber lassen sie mich bei all
dem noch mal die wesentlichen fakten zu
dieser krankheit erläutern
eine von fünf registrierten infizierten
personen wird schwerer erkranken einer
von fünf je nach alter und vorerkrankung
steigt die wahrscheinlichkeit eines
schweren krankheitsverlaufes das heißt
also je älter und je mehr
grundkrankheiten jemand hat ist und je
mehr grundkrankheiten jemand hat desto
größer ist das risiko für ihn schwer zu
erkranken
und wir wissen dass eben auch menschen
an dieser krankheit versterben
es wird also todesfälle geben und es
wird auch in deutschland weiterhin
gestiegene zahl von todesfällen
aber vier von fünf registrierten
infizierten werden nur leichte symptome
erfahren
sie werden nach abklingen der infektion
gesund sein und sie bilden immunität
gegen das virus aus wir wissen noch
nicht wie die sterberate am ende
aussehen wird das wissen wir einfach
nicht aber wenn sie einmal zahlen die in
den letzten wochen immer wieder kurse
und nehmen wir eine zahl von einem
prozent der registrierten dann heißt das
ja dass 99 prozent der registrierten das
überleben
ja ich bitte sie das auch immer klar vor
augen zu haben
also selbst wenn die sterblichkeit so
hoch wäre wie ein prozent dann wurden 99
prozent die krankheit überleben lassen
wir noch betonen
das ist wichtig die ärztinnen und ärzte
die ja veranlassen waren jemand getestet
werden soll oder nicht müssen sich bitte
nach den empfehlungen richten wir müssen
die tests sehr strategisch einsetzen
wir können diese krise nur gut
überstehen wenn wir alle einen kühlen
kopf bewahren
das tun was sie tun können um die
verbreitung einzudämmen
und dazu gehört auch dass ärztinnen und
ärzte dann patienten testen wenn es
geboten ist
tests müssen strategisch eingesetzt
werden denn ansonsten ist natürlich auch
die aussagekraft der zahlen die wir
haben gar nicht so leicht das heißt also
es gibt klare empfehlung von uns waren
zu testen ist oder wann nicht getestet
werden muss wir haben am rk ii mit einem
innovativen ansatz und auch einem sehr
praxisorientierten ansatz
einige der publikationen bislang dazu
nutzen können
die schweren krankheitsverläufe besser
vorherzusagen
das ist ganz wichtig dass mit wir das
einschätzen können und wir wir sehen wir
haben einige werkzeuge entwickelt in den
letzten jahren die habe ich auch schon
mal vor gezeugt vorgestellt sind drei
werkzeuge neben den reinen meldezahlen
ich ihnen immer vermeldet eines ist das
krippe web wo wir viele tausend mit
nutzer haben die dadurch
angeben was für krankheits symptome so
haben dadurch kann man sehr schön sehen
wie die krankheitslast in deutschland
ist wie sich die atemwegsinfektion
entwickeln wird mein zweites tool wo wir
über sentinel praxen das sind also rund
sechs bis sieben 100 praxen in
deutschland von den rund 100 immer so
proben einsendern unser labor so dass
wir jeden tag tausende von proben
teilweise untersuchen die untersuchen
wir auf das vorkommen von bestimmten
viren dort haben wir jetzt auch die
ersten kroner wie ein gefühl und wir
haben ein weiteres werkzeug mit dem wir
den anteil der schwer erkrankten jungen
erkrankten in den krankenhäusern messen
können mit all diesen tools sehen wir
wie sich die krankheitslast entwicklung
können dadurch sehr gut einschätzen wie
der krankheitsverlauf ist und dadurch
natürlich auch steuernd eingreifen
ich habe ihn gestern auch eine
entschuldigung ich glaube das war am
freitag habe ich ihnen auch mitgeteilt
dass wir zusammen mit zwei
gesellschaften ein werkzeugen entwickelt
haben mit dem man die intensivbetten
sehr guten monitoren kann sodass man
also weiß welche krankenhäuser haben
noch intensivbetten kapazitäten frei
welche nicht das ist ein werkzeug das
zunehmend ausgerollt wird das sehr sehr
wichtig sein wird wenn dann strategisch
patienten bestimmten kliniken griff zu
bestimmten kliniken gebracht werden
das heißt wir brauchen viele von diesen
werkzeugen um wirklich optimal das
gesundheitssystem zu nutzen
das tun wir alles gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitssystem um die anzahl der
patienten wie gut versorgt werden können
hochzuhalten in der zukunft aber ich
möchte auch noch mal sagen dass
natürlich die bürgerinnen und bürger
vieles dazu tun können wie wir das seit
drei wochen glaube ich mache jetzt das
pressebriefing etwa sagen bitte halten
sie abstand bitte halten sie quarantäne
ein wenn sie den auferlegt wird vom
gesundheitsamt sorgen sie dafür dass
wenn sie erkrankt sind sie in ihre
armbeuge niesen dass das virus nicht
über ihre hände weitergetragen wird
waschen sie sich die hände waschen sich
die hände intensiv so oft sie können und
wenn sie das nicht können keine
gelegenheit haben nehmen sie sich an
desinfektionsmittel in der tasche
mitteln können sie ab und zu ihre hände
desinfizieren
ich würde es nochmal sagen dass die
meisten ja nur mild erkranken
aber wir müssen immer im auge haben dass
wir viele schwer erkrankte haben die wir
behandeln werden wollen weiterhin
behandeln wollen darum müssen die
epidemie verlangsamt je mehr wir sie
verlangsamen mit den maßnahmen die ich
ihn vorgestellt hat desto mehr können
wir gut versorgen
dafür tragen wir alle zusammen die
verantwortung wie man so schön sagt mit
heißem herz aber kühlem kopf
das müssen wir von uns allen abverlangen
und das können wir auch das heißt also
jeder einzelne kann wirklich etwas dazu
tun alle die maßnahmen die wir seit
wochen ihn nennen auch ganz bewusst
durchzuhalten
wir werden diesen weg der strategischen
bekämpfung von kogit 19 weitergehen
und dazu gehört ist eben auch eine
verantwortungsbewusste kommunikation
durchzuführen auch eine transparente
information so wie wir das seit wochen
tun und auch weiterhin tun werden und
wir brauchen natürlich eine klare
sachliche risikoanalyse auch dass das
können sie dessen können sich versichert
sein werden wir in den nächsten wochen
und monaten tun
klar ist dass wir wirklich alle viel
solidarität zeigen sollten in den
nächsten wochen und monaten
und ich bin auch sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir das tun werden
dankeschön vielen dank fragen sie und
wie gesagt relativ laut sprechen und ich
wiederhole es dann kurz damit die
zuhörer das auch
verkündete ergebnis jedoch relativ
wieder ausmachen also zb die karten
baumarkt oder reicht das aus und das
eigentlich anschließend wurde in zehn
tagen wenn man darin endlich sehen regel
weisen frauen heißt denn was muss ich
denn da entwickeln nach übersicht ja
ganz kurz die wiederholung für die idee
uns online oder über fernsehen zu
schauen
es ist gefragt worden wie die maßnahmen
der bundesregierung eingesetzt werden
es gebe viele ausnahmen und dann noch
die frage wie man man die ersten
ergebnisse sieht von diesen maßnahmen
oder positiven entwicklung also das
rationale ist ja ganz einfach wenn ich
glaube haben wir auch öfter schon
darüber diskutiert hier in diesem forum
und auch sie sicher auch schon mit
freunden und bekannten
je weniger intensive kontakte man zu
anderen personen hat desto schwerer wird
es dem virus gemacht sich auszubreiten
insofern sind das absolut absolut
angemessene maßnahmen ja wann wir sehen
werden ob diese maßnahmen greifen wie
sie greifen
das hängt in erster linie von einer zahl
ab die wir als inkubationszeit
inkubationszeit benennen wir haben wir
eine inkubationszeit von etwa 14 tagen
das heißt also das ist eine maß größe
die wir mal so im kopf haben ob das
stimmt werden wir sehen
aber klar ist dass wir natürlich an dem
verlauf der meldezahlen und an dem was
wir messen in deutschland an dem verlauf
der schweren krankheits fälle
einschätzen können ob diese maßnahmen
greifen oder nicht sie sind sinnvoll und
deshalb bin ich optimistisch dass sie
dazu beitragen das virus zu verlangsamen
dennoch mal das virus von mensch zu
mensch übertragen das heißt also wenn
ich die menschlichen kontakte reduzieren
wird es dem virus schwer gemacht sich zu
verbreiten
noch kurz die wiederholung die frage ob
deutschland die regierung zu langsam
reagiert die drastischen maßnahmen
machen die anderen immer zuerst
fragezeichen
also ich kann das nicht beurteilen ob
alle anderen ländern war alles zuerst
macht aber klar ist folgendes das habe
ich auch versucht zu vermitteln in den
letzten wochen
es ist wichtig immer eine
lageeinschätzung zu haben
und wir haben ja wirklich belastbare
informationen dass wir einfach diese
erkrankungen oder die den ausbruch der
epidemie in deutschland sehr früh
erkannt haben und dadurch auch zeit
hatten bestimmte maßnahmen in die wege
zu leiten
ich halte das für angemessen und ich
auch ganz offen gesagt wir werden ja
dann wenn diese epidemie vorbei ist
werden viele menschen im hinter hinein
schauen was alles geschehen ist man wird
das dann bewerten wir tun alle das beste
was wir können und ich kann mir auch
vorstellen dass durchaus das eine oder
andere vielleicht im nachhinein als
hätte vielleicht besser sein können
lassen sie uns wenn diese epidemie
vorbei ist kritisch überschauen
ich halte es für angemessen
da denken wir dass die massnahmen
betrifft aufmerksam gemacht haben man
muss nur eine neuinfektion holt also was
ist der status im moment wohl die
frankenhalle ist uns nicht noch mal
aufhören ganz kurz nur die frage wie
lange gefragt wurde wie lange es dauert
bis die pandemie wirklich vorbei ist
oder die erste welle vorbei ja ich
wünschte ich könnte ihnen diese frage
sagt die nicht beantworten
wir gehen von allen oder sagen wir wir
hier im institut und wir sind ja mit
vielen fachleuten international sehr eng
verbunden
immer nur ein beispiel ich selber bin in
einem beratergremium wir sind etwa zwölf
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
die auf die welt verteilt sind wir
beraten mike ryan das ist ja der chef
des welt der world als im mercy
programmes das ist einer der menschen
auf der welt verdient die größte
hochachtung habe ein fantastischer
krisenmanager der der sein ganzes leben
dar einsetzt und ich hoffe nur dass er
dass er diesen ganzen stress übersteht
so wie wir sind sehr sehr gut informiert
wir gehen davon aus und das haben wir ja
auch hier schon häufiger gesagt dass wir
von zwei jahren sagen wir mal ob wir ihn
von jahren waren diese pandemie
vielleicht einmal um die welt gegangen
ist pandemien verlaufen in wellen
das wissen wir das ist sicher aber wie
schnell diese wellen sind und wann dann
diese von denen wir immer sprechen 60
bis 70 prozent der person weltweit der
menschen weltweit infiziert ist das wird
jahre dauern sagen ich erhalte eine zahl
von mir aus zwei jahre aber das hängt
natürlich dann auch stark davon ab von
den impfstoff einsetzen können ist ja
klar
jede intervention zu möglichkeit die uns
an die hand gegeben wird ist natürlich
hilfreich und je früher ein impfstoff
kommt desto schneller wird dann auch die
pandemie eingegrenzt werden können aber
nur weil ein impfstoff da ist heißt es
ja auch noch nicht dass alle menschen
geimpft werden
es gibt ja kapazitäten von impfstoffen
und wir müssen ja auch geimpft werde das
heißt wir werden auch sehr viele
menschen haben wir ja 99 prozent von
allen registrierten sind haben das ja
überstanden haben eine immunität
wir wissen ja auch nach den heutigen
kenntnissen die wir haben ist es so dass
wir vielleicht die hälfte von allen die
infiziert werden überhaupt krank wer
eines der status heute es gibt kaum eine
infektionskrankheit wohl jeder der
infiziert wird krank wird bei diesem
virus scheint es so zu sein nach dem
heutigen wissen dass etwa die hälfte
überhaupt nur krank wenn das heißt die
andere hälfte sehen wir ja gar nicht die
sind infiziert haben nichts gemerkt
haben die immunität ja also wir reden
auch über monate wir gehen auf einem
zeitraum von zwei jahren aus stehen
könnte ich gleich beantworten ja also
ich gehe nach wie vor davon aus dass es
gibt ja folgendes zu verstehen
impfstoffe haben wir ja schon häufig
gesagt die werden sehr schnell fertig
sein also werden in wenigen wochen
werden wir impfstoffkandidaten haben
aber impfstoffe müssen ja erst immer
getestet werden das heißt es gibt es
zwei dinge die uns interessieren als als
wissenschaftler aber auch als
verantwortungsträger die dann einen
solchen impfstoff federn zu lassen der
wird dann irgendwann an menschen dann
eben auch angewendet
das ist das profil bezogen auf den
schutz also wie gut schützt der
impfstoff das muss man ja auch austesten
und das zweite was aber genauso wichtig
ist es eben ist ja auch sicher es gibt
ja prinzipiell die möglichkeit von
nebenwirkungen und die muss man
natürlich austesten und wenn man eine
nebenwirkung austestet dann kann man das
auch nicht von einem tag auf den anderen
tun sondern das braucht auch ein paar
wochen bis man das beobachtet das heißt
also die ganzen klinischen testung in
die werden nach wie vor wochen lang
dauern
aber was ich weiß und was ich was sehr
erfreulich ist in den letzten jahren hat
die internationale gemeinschaft schon
ist schon sehr viel zusammengerückt und
haben sehr viel mechanismen entwickelt
um
dies zu beschleunigen und auch gerade
die zulassungsbehörde ja unheimlich
wichtig sind dass eben kein keine
medikamente auf den markt kommen die
eben nicht seriösen oder nebenwirkungen
haben auch die können bestimmte
verfahren beschleunigen
aber ich bin trotzdem davon überzeugt
dass ein impfstoff erst anfang erst im
nächsten jahr zur verfügung steht
jeder monat ich sage also vor frühe im
nächsten jahr kann ich persönlich ist
nicht annehmen aber jeden monat nehme
ich mich sehr freue ich mich natürlich
ja klar
dies wurde gefragt ob bewegungsdaten
ausgewertet werden ja also wir halten
das für ein sinnhaftes konzept ja es
gibt da verschiedene aspekte abzuwägen
die kennen sie alles gibt datenschutz
aspekte es gibt technische aspekte
ich sage nur so viel hier ich bin nach
meinem kenntnisstand davon überzeugt
dass beide aspekte bewältigt werden
können
und der vorteil wäre natürlich dass wir
die gesundheitsämter enorm unterstützen
sie müssen sich ja vorstellen wie
geschieht die kontakt nachverfolgung das
ist so dass ein patient wird
diagnostiziert dass er ein fall ist also
er hat einen positiven testergebnis und
dann ist die aufgabe des
gesundheitsamtes mit dieser person zu
sprechen sie zu interviewen und zu
fahren mit wem hattest du dein kontakt
intensiven in den letzten beiden wochen
um dann risikopatienten zu
identifizieren die dann wiederum befragt
werden und je nachdem wir haben ja
verschiedene kategorien das ja ganz
strategisch ganz logisch aufgebaut oder
wenn man ein sehr enge kontaktpersonen
war dann wäre man eine person das gerade
ist eins der kategorie eins dann sollte
man in häusliche quarantäne gehen und so
weiter also verschiedene verschiedene
maßnahmen an
und das ist natürlich ein 1 1 ein
prozess der eine zeit in der zeit kostet
wenn sie sich vorstellen dass es möglich
wäre herauszufinden anhand einer
bestimmten applikation wer denn in den
letzten zwei wochen in einer bestimmten
entfernung und für eine bestimmte zeit
in dieser entfernung gewesen wäre dann
wäre das natürlich zielgenauer diese
personen direkt zu kontaktieren und ich
sage noch mal dass ich technisch möglich
und es ist auch datenschutzrechtlich
möglich ich bin sehr optimistisch dass
uns das gelingen wird und wir arbeiten
daran mit einem team die alle ein team
von 25 leuten die auf zwölf
verschiedenen institutionen kommen und
die dass alle seit drei wochen wirklich
sieben tage die woche bearbeiten ohne
dafür bislang auch nur annähernd
irgendwelche entlohnung bekommen zu
haben sind alles menschen die diesem
land dienen wollen die solidarität in
hohem maß aufbauen und ich bin sehr
optimistisch dass das gelingen wird wir
werden das sehen das liegt nicht in
meiner hand alleine aber ich bin sehr
optimistisch dass wir ein überzeugendes
konzept haben wir einen kurzen
das erst zwei jahre bauen kann
diese entscheidung war noch zwei jahre
wenn sie das ganz stringent durch denken
wäre das eine logik wir werden sehen wie
stark wir es eingrenzen können und dann
wird man sehen wie die massnahmen
angepasst werden das ist wirklich eine
betrachtungsweise die wir kontinuierlich
durch für müssen ja wie gesagt im im
extremen fall bestünde diese möglichkeit
wir werden sie in ob es so ist
ich kann die frage noch mal wiederholen
aber es ist tatsächlich nichts zu tun es
ging um die frage ob die amerikaner sich
impfstoffe sichern können oder rechte an
impfstoffen sichern kann
also jede maßnahme die nicht solidarisch
ist bewerte ich natürlich als
unsolidarisch ja wenn es diese versuch
tatsächlich gegeben hat dann dann ist
das bedauerlich
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen ich weiß
nur dass die firma zu weg ein sehr
innovatives produkt hat nämlich dass da
geht es um folgendes sie entwickeln und
da sind sich die einzige firma es gibt
auch eine andere firma die dieses kunden
oder dieser diese möglichkeit hat eine
andere firma die das auch kann der
impfstoff funktioniert folgendermaßen
das ist ein sehr innovatives projekt
aber ich muss dazu sagen es gibt bislang
keinen zugelassenen impfstoff ja also ob
das projekt gelingt werden wir sehen
es geht darum dass man eben nicht den
konventionellen impfstoff anwendet also
man initiiert quasi teile von einem
virus in dem falle damit der körper
gegen dieses virus dann eine immunität
auf bildet gibt es 22 arme der immunität
des eine sind die die antikörper das
andere sind die t zellen und und viel
besser man diese immunität anwirft desto
stärker ist der schutz
hier ist das konzept ein anderes und das
konzept wurde eben schon erfolgreich in
der tumortherapie angewendet hier wird
eine also einfach nur rna also gen
material wird injiziert und dieses gen
material wird gezielt in bestimmte
zellen geschleust und diese zellen
werden dann quasi dazu aktiviert sofort
gegen die von dem genmaterial gebilden
stoffe proteine des virus eine
immunantwort zu starten und das ist das
innovative das heißt die ganze
immunantwort uhr zum einen sehr sehr
gezielt aktiviert und zum anderen auch
schneller auf aktiviert dieses konzept
hat in der onkologie ist es bereits
angewendet es hat dort erfolge zeigten
darum sind viele wissenschaftler
hoffnungsfroh dass das auch für einen
impfstoff sein wird aber bislang muss
ich sagen sind es eben vorwiegend
versuche
im tiermodell wir werden schauen ob sich
dieser impfstoff durchsetzt wenn wäre es
großartig weil es schnell ist weil es
effizient ist und weil es sogar auch
kostengünstig ist also es ist schon es
ist ein sehr innovatives konzept aber
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass es eben
noch experimentell ist und wir müssen
eben auch die konventionellen impfstoffe
da gibt es ja auch tolle modelle ohne
das jetzt im detail zu vertiefen
wir müssen natürlich auch dafür sorge
tragen dass die konventionellen im
stoffe die auch sehr innovativ sind
ebenfalls weiter untersucht werden dafür
braucht es dann eben einen
internationalen mechanismus irgendwann
muss man dann ja quasi entscheiden
welchen impfstoff wird man dann jetzt
präferieren und in die produktion
bringen und darum ist die internationale
zusammenarbeit so weit und da kann ich
ihnen nur versichern dass eben auch die
wissenschaftler international dort eine
hohe solidarität haben wiederholt es
ging um die frage wie was die
hochstufung der risikoeinschätzung auf
hoch jetzt bedeutet und ob mit einer
ausgangssperre zu rechnen
ja die hochstufung frucht der die
maßnahmen wurden ja gestern verkündet
also ich kann nur alle wirklich darum
dazu ermahnen oder ermuntern dass sie
die maßnahmen die gestern genannt wurden
dass die eingehalten werden ja ganz
einfach
das heißt das öffentliche leben ist
eingeschränkt weniger mobilität weniger
kontakt zu anderen menschen das bedeutet
dass die risikoabschätzung auf
hochgestuft wird
ja sehr hoch ja mehr stufen haben wir
nicht zu vergeben
sie hatten noch dahin es gibt momentan
28.000 die krankenhausgesellschaft
markiert also man kann es auf 34.000
hoch fahren gibt es denn eine
alternative muss jeder kranke der
terrorismus wirklich intensiv welt
gekommen die frage ob jeder kranke der
ins krankenhaus kommt ein intensiv mit
braucht und ob man das verdoppeln kann
also wer intensivmedizinisch behandelt
werden muss können ja nur die ärzte vor
ort entscheiden das ist ja klar aber es
gibt noch menge möglichkeiten um die
anzahl der betten zu erhöhen
es gibt viele möglichkeiten die ich im
einzelnen gar nicht kenne aber ich
spreche auch mit klinikchefs mit ärzten
es gibt noch eine reihe von
möglichkeiten die aufzustocken
und es gibt natürlich auch einfache
verhältnisse einfach betten die man
aufbauen kann und wo man beatmung
durchführen kann ohne dass man den den
normalen standard den wir in kliniken
zur zeit sehe neben dann noch fahren
könnten das ist ja auch klar sie
erinnern sich vielleicht an die kliniken
die in haan aufgebaut wurden in sehr
sehr kurzer zeit
das waren auch sehr sehr einfache
räumlichkeiten aber sie diente neben
dazu patienten atmen zu können
und das ist natürlich möglich also wir
haben hier noch möglichkeiten die
kapazitäten zu erhöhen
strategisch was bedeutet dass es gibt
immer mehr berichte unserer langen
wartezeiten
es wäre die erste frage zusammen
zeichners und kliniken
ganz kurz die rolle für die zuhörer
was bedeutet das dass die test
strategisch eingesetzt werden sollen und
die frage was alarm ein alarmzeichen bei
uns eingegangen ist
ja also wir haben ich will das noch mal
kurz den ablauf
was wir hier am robert-koch-institut tun
warum wir das tun seit dem 6 januar also
jetzt das sind jetzt schon das sind zwei
monaten seit dem 6 januar
das ist dreimal für die seit dem
sechsten januar arbeiten wir mit einer
arbeitsgruppe die das geschehen
betrachtet vierzehnter januar haben wir
das erhöht haben wir also mehr
mitarbeiter quasi mit der analyse der
der deutschen und der internationalen
befasst dann hatten wir den ersten fall
in deutschland das war der 27 januar
da hatten wir den ausbruch den wir in
bayern hatten und und die zwei
repatriierten die in frankfurt behandelt
wurde uns alle kerngesund inzwischen die
16 haben wir alle überlebt und sind
kerngesund
die 16 personen die wir damals in
deutschland als erste identifiziert
hatten und dann kam die fälle in
heimsheim und das heißt wir arbeiten
also jetzt seit diesen monaten arbeiten
wir intensiv daran empfehlungen zu
erstellen und die empfehlungen sind ja
zunächst mal unsere empfehlungen sind
eher für ärzte wir sind dafür da den
ärzten in deutschland eine handreichung
zu geben wie sie sich zu verhalten haben
wir brauchen sie brauchen empfehlungen
was soll ich tun einrahmen den
einzelfall muss natürlich jeder einzelne
immer noch regeln aber wir geben
empfehlungen so und die empfehlungen die
wir unter anderem erarbeitet haben ist
ein flussdiagramm wir inzwischen so
viele empfehlungen das ist wohl ein
riesen dokumenten schrank geworden und
werden unter anderem einfluss schema
entwickelt wir entwickeln fluss schemata
nicht um jeden einzelfall zu regeln
sondern um das prinzip zu vermitteln und
nehmen wir ein beispiel jemand war in
einem risikogebiet der grund warum wir
risikogebiete definieren hatte ich
gerade gesagt nein also diese vier
kriterien jemand war in einem
risikogebiet
er kommt zurück nach hause und er
erkrankt er kriegt schnupfen husten
fieber
wenn er jetzt in einem risikogebiet
gewesen ist dann ist ja die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass er vielleicht
angesteckt wurde größer als wenn er
nicht in einem risikogebiet gewesen wäre
das heißt also da hat zum beispiel ein
arzt von uns die empfehlung bekommen den
sollte er testen wenn er mal
irgendjemand gar nicht in einem
risikogebiet war und leichte symptome
hat dann ist ja die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass er dass die infektion hat geringer
dann muss er nicht getestet werden das
meine ich mit strategisch da gibt es
eine menge andere punkte die können sie
sich auch noch mal gerne anschauen auf
diesen auf diesen fluss schemata oder es
gibt dann im rahmen von ausbruchs
untersuchen die das gesundheitsamt
durchführt da gibt es eben auch
bestimmte menschen die man kategorisiert
einfach risikopartie 1 die müssen
getestet werden usw
das heißt also dass man sich mit
strategisch warum ist das so wichtig
dann geht es zum einen natürlich um die
kapazität ja wir haben die kapazität ist
in deutschland sehr sehr groß wir können
über 160.000 tests machen pro woche etwa
und das kann man auch noch steigern ja
aber es ist natürlich klar dass es
personen gibt die aus den ganzen
epidemiologischen überlegungen die wir
ja machen vielleicht eher getestet
werden sollten als andere und das ist
strategisch der das heißt also die ärzte
haben mir auch die pflicht das zu
klassifizieren und die zu testen von
denen sie denken bei denen macht es mehr
sinn oder nicht das ist nichts weiter
als die ärztliche fürsorgepflicht
schauen sie stellen sich vor es gäbe
dieses kogit 19 nicht
und die gehen mit atemwegserkrankungen
zum arzt
ja dann geht der arzt schaut sie an
macht eine anamnese und sagt ob du okay
gehen wir nach hause bleibt man eine
woche zu hause ich war schreibt ihr dies
oder jenes und guck mal wie es
weitergeht
oder er sagt was hier sieht aber noch
einer schweren erkrankung aus dass
könnten in florenz sein lasst uns mal an
influenza test machen ja dass die
differentialdiagnose dass das ist der
job der teppich job eines jeden arztes
hierzu
mit dem patienten umzugehen ihnen
entweder zu sagen bleibt zu hause das
kannst du aus oder ich weise dich ins
krankenhaus ein ich mache die franzi ahl
diagnose oder nicht das ist alltag
unabhängig von kogit 19 dafür sind ärzte
ausgebildet und wir geben in
empfehlungen wie sie diese werkzeuge die
ihnen zur verfügung stehen strategisch
nutzen so alarmzeichen kliniken heißt
das eben die anzahl der schwer kranken
zunimmt
das heißt also hinzu sie haben zunehmend
patienten die eben intensivmedizinisch
betreut wenn müssen beatmet werden
müssen das heißt die fallzahlen nehmen
zu so wie das ja auch zu erwarten ist
wir sagen seit wochen dass wir am beginn
einer epidemie stehen dh die zahlen
nähmen zu die zahl der schwerkranken
nehmen zu die zahl der verstorbenen
nehmen zu und das heißt dass in
bestimmten kliniken dass die das schon
sehen und uns auch spiegeln dass die
epidemie eben angekommen ist und das
wichtige ist eben es gibt regionen wo
das eben gar nicht so ist
es gibt regionen in deutschland wo diese
krankheit überhaupt keine rolle spielt
in der wahrnehmung der öffentlichkeit
oder der krankenhäuser aber sie wird
auch dahin kommen
und darum sagen wir alle krankenhäuser
müssen die formal damit hat man uns ganz
herzlich und üblich noch ein kurzes
statement
draußen im foyer hat noch zehn minuten
zeit also wenn sie sich sputen oder
signalisieren dass es nicht mehr
benötigt wird auch recht ja das war sie
die pressekonferenz des
robert-koch-instituts wie jeden tag
momentan während der korona krise um 10
uhr live hier bei phoenix vielleicht
noch mal das wichtigste zusammengefasst
die risikoeinschätzung ich glaube dass
war das wichtigste in dieser
pressekonferenz ist jetzt auf hoch
gestellt worden
das heißt